give it up for the one and only Tony
henli the story is kind of crazy I think
you guys are in for a little bit of a
treat so here's the exclusive is that
obviously it was a coordinated attack
obviously he's in cahoots with the
Chinese media when you open your phone
and you're on the front page of [__]
everything for a joke whatever you do do
not
apologize Tony so we had uh when we had
Uncle Roger on the show he was like it's
so good to be on the show that you do
when you get cancelled yeah so welcome
yeah you were canceled a while ago that
but you haven't really talked much about
it and we were hanging out the other day
and it's something we really wanted to
discuss with you so tell everybody what
happened first of all well I mean this
was in May of 2021 and I was doing a
very routine Thursday workout set I mean
very routine it's called The Secret Show
and it's called that because none of the
names are announced on the show um which
means that you as in my position you
know as someone that's been doing this
for over a decade and a half standup
comedy you know you don't have any
pressure on you so you don't have to
necessarily do your a
material um you have a chance to work
out new stuff you can bomb if you want
technically I mean I don't go in with
those intentions but it is that kind of
show so it's literally the last show
that you would expect to get cancelled
on it was at a big aluminum bar on Sixth
Street called the Vulcan gas company
which we made our temporary home um
during the pandemic when Joe was
building up his Club so again just a
throwaway set on a throwaway night a
throwaway show a throwaway lineup just
no expectations of anything very routine
Thursday and um and uh I roll in and I
always get to go on whenever I want on
that show cuz technically how sad of a
world this is but I'm the big celebrity
on a show like that that is sad yeah
exactly
depressing um so I walk in there's a
comedian on stage I recognize him as
Pang dang a guy that I had opened for me
quite a few times in Dallas Texas pulled
him out of the bucket on kill Tony all
many years ago five six years ago I
thought he was Charming
um and uh you know very Asian so it's
like different than me so it's fun to
have someone like that open for you um
so he opened for me a few times in
Dallas he was on Kil Tony uh at least
once and so I knew that he knew me I
know him and he's going on and on during
his set about how white people are so
bad and Asian people have done all this
great stuff and you know this is during
uh uh what they were trying to make um
appear to be Asian hate time like that
was different during that time uh
because there was a lot of homeless
people that with mental illness
attacking Asian people in New York city
so the media tried to make that a
storyline like it was
some you know epidemic that's happened
like people in a comedy club need to be
lectured about it cuz that will stop
homeless people in New York right right
yeah I mean wild with the media covers
and what they don't cover and uh it was
Asian Heritage Month month which no one
knew at the time that was that was never
a thing I do a thing to this day where
if I meet a likable Asian person I ask
them hey do you know what Asian Heritage
Month is and they never know it's May by
the way I'll never forget that one again
anyway so he's going on and on and he's
also uh I do believe he went slightly
over his time this is there's just a
thing that I've always done done I was
built in the darkness of The Comedy
Store in La at a very dark time with
very you know the comedy wasn't even
that cool yet it was more of a carnival
type of thing back then the leading you
know Chappelle was retired and Dane Cook
was on top and it was like it was just a
dark time for the art form and there was
no Netflix there was no real you there
was no YouTube specials so it was just
up to HBO kind of In Comedy Central
which was a sinking ship anyway my point
is that the time when I started when I
was constructed as a comedian was so
dark and I've always been a maker funner
of people a raster before that was even
a famous word you know it wasn't you
know if I could take you back to 2007
you'd be surprised to know that there
were roast they called them roast oh
there's the old roast with uh um Dean
Martin and there's the Comedy Central
roast that happens every other year but
it wasn't a term like it is now anyway
so I got good at it I got really you
know I worked on it and so I became
known for that everybody knows that I
make fun of people anyway so cut back to
the night that show I am already
frustrated because he's going a little
long I just want to get up and get out
of there he's saying that white people
basically ain't [__] and the it felt
like it was kind of like you know
another thing about that show
specifically is sometimes they get a
dumb crowd yeah you know they're going
to a workout show on a Thursday night
they don't know who's going to be there
so they're kind of chuckling along and
I'm thinking to myself these [__]
idiots are laughing at [__] you know
kind of like you I don't want to say
Lefty leaning but it kind of was that
night a groan Lefty leaning kind of
crowd that's kind of
like not laughing but giggling at this
stuff that that he was saying because
they felt like he had the timing of it
being funny but if you watch the video
it ain't really funny anyway so it's all
boiling up and I figure okay I'm going
to take a few Jabs at him by the way I
didn't even know he was Chinese I was
going to use the c-word on him whether
he was Japanese whatever you know didn't
matter to me I was just in the mood to
use a funny Dark word that's how I often
establish my sets at the top I like to
hit them so that the rest of the set
they're like okay we know what we're in
for with this guy
right um so yeah it happened I made fun
of them the famous uh very well edited
by him clip hello good evening welcome
hello how about one more time for the
filthy little [__] CH that was just
up here while all you [__] race
Traders are hooping and
hollering I'm back there watching you
puking in a [__] bucket oh we Mak
going to gunpowder oh you want extra soy
sauce oh you borrow money from us and
you guys just eating it up you [__]
[__] fun facts about the moment that it
happened were was um um you know I had a
camera
rolling um for my set um that was
rolling throughout the night we don't
ever do anything with anybody else's set
but he didn't know that there was a
camera rolling throughout the night and
when he found out that he was bringing
me up he asked Redban the co- um host
and producer of Kil Tony guy that I've
worked with we've made you know worked
together for over a decade um he asked
him it's his show if he could record his
set which is you know rare in Texas for
that Austin for that to happen but
redband gave him permission redband
thought it was interesting that he asked
after he found out that he was bringing
me up that's something to remember for
later this story is kind of crazy I
think you guys are in for a little bit
of a treat um and I notice that
someone's recording from the audience
and it was the friend that he asked to
record his
set but I ignore it
um uh I I I noticed that it ends a
couple minutes after I'm up there I'm
already into material so I don't care
who cares if they recorded me making fun
of Pang dang you know on a random show
no big deal if anything I figured if
anything were to happen with that clip
he would post it under the type of uh
caption of so fun to be roasted by my
pal you know someone that I look up to
literally um so uh that's that that was
a Thursday night Friday Saturday Sunday
Monday Monday night and I have for some
reason this crazy
dream that I'll never forget and this is
like totally off subject and kind of
corny but I have this weird dream about
my old house and I'm in the backyard of
my old house and there's another floor
above that was never there and I'm
looking and I go what is that third
floor and I go in and everything's
different you know how weird dreams are
and I'm going up this like ladder spir
spiral staircase it's all weird and it's
like all old creepy [__] there's like
old dolls on the walls and stuff and
it's just creepy one of those weird what
is all this what does this mean like
nightmares and I wake up and it's like I
think like 4:30 or 5:00 a.m. or
something like that it's Tuesday morning
and I look at my phone cuz I'm like Wide
Awake kind of like you know you want to
go right back to sleep but the dream was
so weird that you're kind of like GH so
I'm looking at my phone and I check
Twitter for some reason and I
have it says you know when you hit the
max it says just says 20 plus y you know
what I mean and I'm like that's weird I
went to bed whatever 4 hours ago
probably checked it then or whatever and
I click on it and it's all these
misspelled diabolically like
weird words in wrong places ass you
are [__] [__] of you you got messaged by
Yoda a lot yes a lot
I mean just every asan Yoda different
combinations of words you you you suck
[__] nothing will you be ever shall you
fail like I'm like what is all this I
mean it sounds mystical oh I know and
I'm literally like what is going on what
in the world is going on so I end up
clicking on some of the profiles to see
like what are they even referencing like
you normally if you click on something
there's like a video or something under
that you know and then you see what
they're commenting on or anything but
there wasn't anything to comment on but
I click on another profile and another
profile and I'm clearly seeing that it's
Asian but all these people have zero
followers for some reason zero posts is
a big thing very common with this so I
have no idea what's going
on and then I find one that has a
video
um and there's Chinese captions and then
there's a whole Chinese
letter um Chinese written article
underneath it so I copy and I paste it
into a
translator and it says this is where
things get weird I think you guys will
appreciate this CU my cancellation is
kind of special and weird in a way um
kind of like you Tony yeah yeah I think
so so I translate it and it literally
says Chinese American comedian Pang dang
was um what are they what what was the
radical terminology that they used I
mean it was uh you know was
racially whatever I can't even I can't
even think of it it's racially abused oh
yes something like that just ridiculous
verbage um by Tony henchcliffe it
doesn't say rooster it doesn't say
comedian I find it all so
interesting and um it said comedian Pang
dang tweeted at
11:15 am that this and it was what he
said but what's interesting if you
remember is that it's 4:45 5 a.m. 11:15
a.m. on Tuesday which I'm reading in the
translator hasn't happened yet I go to
Pang dang's Twitter to see if he's
tweeted anything and he hasn't yes there
is no video there is no tweet 11:15
hasn't happened
yet so I'm like I don't know what any of
this means this is so weird who gives a
[__] I'm going back to bed fall asleep
wake up an hour later hundreds more you
[__] die [__] brain brain [__] [__] you
die die die you going to die die you
gonna gonna you die I mean all of these
things and I'm just scrolling like what
the [__] is going on it's getting bigger
I fall asleep wake up an hour later it's
getting bigger now it's like I wake up
and I'm actually awake now it's like
10:30 I check again Pang dang hasn't
tweeted this thing what is going on what
is this article
11:14 11:15 and now I'm looking at it
because I'm getting all of these things
from this one big Chinese article makes
sense now it's coming from China they're
not allowed on Twitter so that's why
they have zero posts that's why they
have zero followers this is their one
way way of harassing somebody in America
is by creating a fake screen name or
whatever logging on and saying a bunch
of jibber jabber out of place [__]
11:15 happens and there it is Pang dang
tweets and I remember seeing it with
zero likes and zero retweets I saw the
tweet I saw the
video the interesting thing that I
forgot to mention is that in the Chinese
one it's in Chinese caption I think it's
like neon green or something like that
and these American captions that are
tweeted at 11:15 in English are neon
green so immediately I'm like okay
whoever made that made that and this was
a coordinated without a doubt this was
coordinated over the weekend an attack
on me so blatantly blatantly and this
has never been you know I never blew
this up anywhere or anything this is
exclusive trigonometry
uh this is what we build this channel
for yeah yeah cuz I mean I made it
through this I'm wildly more successful
thank God than I've ever been so here's
the exclusive is that obviously it was a
coordinated attack obviously he's in
cahoots with the Chinese media you know
what I mean
like
um uh it's just blatant they did a
report about a tweet that didn't happen
and they [__] up because they didn't
get the time right however the time
zones or whatever somebody [__] up cuz
they leaked the story before it even
happened so 11:15 The Tweak goes out and
again right then in that moment I'm
still thinking to myself cuz I haven't
put it together this is a cancellation
that this thing's going to blow up I'm
literally thinking to myself Pang dang
what the hell you you didn't write this
right like what he wrote in the caption
was whatever um it's a
uh terrible that I was um insulted in
this way blah blah blah happy Asian
Heritage Month # Asian Heritage Month #
whatever he tried to get as much
traction as he could and I'm thinking to
myself literally still at that point I'm
like his captions wrong like I'm like I
want to I'm going to hit him up and be
like yo fix your caption you're making
me look bad I had no idea you thought
what was happening is what happens
between comedians which is when we take
the piss out of each other we we make it
look like I've been insulted but it's a
[__] joke exactly so you hit him up
no
response and I hit him up on Instagram
no response and I hit up my buddy who
also has him open for him I go hit up
hang dang have him call me what is going
on because this thing is starting to
click click click click click 100 likes
500 likes 800 comments the the ratio on
it was insane because this is also we're
in like almost Peak virtue signaling
time May 2021 is oh yeah oh yeah I think
the vaccine's just rolling out right
around then I mean everybody's just you
know it's a weird [__] time we're 11
months out of George Floyd but but still
you know most of the a lot of the
country closed closed again reclosed so
just a weird time for anything to happen
um and
um so my buddy says that he talked to
Pang dang and Pang dang doesn't want to
talk to
me which is also so interesting because
he starts going to Media Outlets
immediately blowing this thing up I mean
you know I'm getting hit up by everyone
it starts coming in my agents my
managers Washington Post New York Times
wants to talk to you because everybody's
picking up this you know story that
involves rap and these disgusting
disgusting media people want their
clickbait so I turn everything down of
course because what the [__] do I have
to defend what am I going to do really
am I going to say it was a joke that's
my style but of course they all write it
up none of these journalists have any
Integrity or common sense whatsoever I
thought news was fake before but let me
tell you when you're in the storm you're
like holy [__] these [__] if
you Google me the first thing that pops
up is Tony henchcliffe is an American
insult comedian famous for making fun of
Comedians and writing for The Comedy
Central roast like it's literally the
backbone of what I do even though I've
been doing standup comedy for 16 and a
half years I'm best known for making fun
of comedians whether it be writing on
the roast hosting kill Tony and just in
normal life if you see me in a green
room you know whatever ever it's just
what I do to everybody I hold back
anytime I see anybody I scan them and I
think of what I would say it's a defense
mechanism from having too big of a head
when I was in kindergarten the same size
head that I have now when I was in
kindergarten but a little body so like
there's my chin there's the top of my
head there's the rest of my body so you
had like one of those wobble heads yes
big time I mean it was [__]
grotesque but it's the same size head
that I have now so I grew into
it only took an extra 3T of grow to fit
into it properly I do feel sorry for
your mother though Tony if that was the
size of the head well I was the fifth
kid of hers so I came out like a I came
out like a water slide that thing was
that thing was ready for me my mom's got
a giant giant [__] you know what I'm
talking about all right
so
um uh so it happens my agent says don't
worry we're going to get through this
everything's going to be fine my manager
who I actually really really really um
liked at the time is like I'm here for
you we're going to stick with
you
um
so as it's all happening you know just
dread kind of is setting in but also I'm
like this is fine news articles who
cares this is going to blow over I go
have dinner that night with my
girlfriend at our favorite little sushi
restaurant I'm starving but I also don't
have an appetite and I talk to Joe and
he's like dude this is not good I'm like
oh
[__] now I know it's not good now I know
something's wrong because it's just a
bad time and he's like this is bad news
and you know there's a lot of [__]
death threats on you coming in I'm
seeing a lot of hate let's not do let's
why don't you take a couple nights off
of these shows tomorrow just little
throwaway shows at a little dinky Comedy
Club around the corner which is fine who
cares right take a couple nights off I
don't ever get to do
that um but once they take my name off
of that
lineup um then there's a new news
article and the news article is Tony
hinchcliff removed from Joe Rogan shows
because of racial blah blah blah blah
blah so now people online are going haha
your buddy just stabbed you in the back
shame on Joe stab you know these people
don't know anything they don't know that
it was a throwaway 20 minutes set anyway
but they smell blood exactly and that's
all anybody cares about so now there's a
new news article that night about Tony
hinchcliff off of Joe Rogan shows so it
keeps it going there's a new news
cycle um the next day it's still going
and at the time it's funny we're talking
about this at the time Israel and
Palestine were bombing each other left
and right back and forth it was the
probably the last big one until this one
that just started a couple days ago but
I remember that because I'm like why is
the news not talking about this why the
hell are they talking about a dirty
comedian at Vulcan gas company on a
Thursday night in Austin [__] Texas
like none of an insult comedian none of
these things are adding up to me like
how in the world what is happening how
am I the news how is me making fun of
some completely unknown comedian that
has probably seven minutes of good
material to his name how is this the
world
news so it but it is I wake up the next
day and by the way I couldn't eat the
sushi after that I couldn't eat that
night I'm starting to get like sick I'm
starting to think holy [__] this is bad
I'm pacing continuously are you thinking
my career could be over here could be
could be it's what it kind of seemed at
the time which is crazy to me because
I'm like there's just no way I can't I
can't get in trouble for making fun of
people that's like you guys getting in
trouble for asking questions that
happens that's the world we live in to
get in trouble for what you do and what
you're supposed to be good at is crazy
to me you guys leave your eggs out
is that a British thing yeah yeah are
you [__] serious you don't keep him
in the fridge no this is amazing are you
how that's you guys are okay tally Focus
no way that's
crazy um I've never seen that in 39
Years of Living in America that's a
British thing how you just leave them
out all the time you don't need to put
them in the fridge you don't need to you
don't have to you have to leave this in
yeah you don't you don't edit this right
we will [__] leave their eggs on the
counter how how much your percentage of
listeners is American about 40% and 60%
British no 4% British 20% the rest of
the world so Americans you've been
educated exactly keep your eggs out put
your eggs in the [__] fridge this is
why we beat their ass in the war of uh
revolutionary times okay so anyway
here's where it starts to get cooking
because the next day I'm like well
yesterday was crazy no way I'm going to
be the world news
today and at about um I also messaged
the venue in which we were doing kill
Tony at the time a uh a really really
really um
small uh venue here in Austin Texas that
famously is like a small
corporate um venue that I only chose as
the home of Kil Tony when we first
arrived here because one of my very good
friends Gary Clark Jr is a part a
partner in the place however he doesn't
run the place he he's not Hands-On and
he was in Australia at the time um very
busy with some very busy stuff that I
won't get into but he was out of the
loop being a creative genius and
um and I to I messaged um the running
partner of that club go hey stuff's
crazy right now but it's going to blow
over trust me if you want to talk about
it give me a call and I'll explain
everything and how we will execute
moving
forward um again very small venue I was
I always felt like I was doing them a
favor by having the show there very very
very very left leaning um venue uh to
where they restricted how many people
were in theice audience so much space in
between the audience and again it's May
2021 we're like what what what are we
doing here cuz we're doing standup shows
where people are shoulder toosh shoulder
every other night of the week basically
but I was playing along with them being
a nice guy and um so I go hit me up if
you have any questions or whatever
moving forward and um that was the day
before I messaged them at about whatever
it was 11: or noon the next day they put
out a press release saying we're no
longer the home of Kil Tony we do not
believe in racism of any kind uh and we
find his words to be intolerable
whatever again this jargon I don't even
remember there's a part of my brain
which remembers a lot of [__] that won't
allow myself even the opportunity to
remember what these virtue signaling
morons both them Pang dang I'm realizing
right now you're watching me realize
that I can't remember the the actual
verbage because I won't let myself it's
so ridiculous to even do that I just
find virtue signaling to be literally
the most disgusting thing in the world
be a good person or don't be a good
person don't make it look like you're a
[__] good person anyway so they put
that out so guess what that's a new
story that's the new news story of the
next day uh this venue which by the way
is it's the service is terrible at the
venue I've seen so many bugs at this
venue either you know the venue or you
don't know the venue don't go there if
you know it and if you don't know it
don't look it up and don't go there um
there you go so uh so now that's a new
news story even though I helped them
throughout the pandemic from uh from
December of 2020 to May of 2021 they sat
empty other nights of the week and I
gave them liquor sale and a full
audience and the coolest show in town
every Monday packed it as much as they
would let me pack it could have done
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
more people but they wanted to appear
like they cared about the safety of
Texans that wanted to see a comedy show
so now there's a new news story sucks
and I'm watching even my favorite news
outlets it sucks when your favorite ones
start covering it right Fox News
comedian goes on racist rant I'm like
what come on guys you're my guys you
can't do this to me anyway everything's
covering it um and
uh and what I chose to do because I was
so stressed out is I went golfing with
Ron White and another really good friend
and I'm explaining to them what's
happening and these guys live in [__]
highrises and castles and ranches and
[__] and they don't know [__] about [__]
especially being cancelled you know
Ron's a Class Act and I remember I uh I
took my girlfriend with me there so
she's driving the golf cart and we were
doing this thing where each hole when I
would get back in the cart I go anything
new and and she was refreshing Tony
hinch cff it's a good way to
relax it was crazy by the way and as you
could probably guess the worst game of
golf I've ever had in my life it's so
interesting to see that like you know it
really is that game it really is
it's a game of mental strength and not
being distracted not being stressed
because little tiny things you know
going the other direction or farther
from the hole than I was before like
comically
bad and uh yeah so every time I go to
the golf cart it was something else it
was weird that I was torturing myself
that way but I was just waiting for the
thing when you're in this like this if
you want to know what it's like to if
people listening since you guys probably
do know but what it's really like is
you're waiting for the storm to pass so
you're kind of looking out the window to
see if there's any light coming right
and that's all I was doing I wasn't like
obsessed with myself it's obsessed it's
I was obsessing with it's got to be any
second now any second there's going to
be not another news article and There
She Goes you know yeah 3 minutes ago the
um LA Times um 7 minutes ago Fox News
and yeah they wrote another one I go
another one you know it's like it's the
same ones of writing other ones and then
at about 4: or 5 p.m. that day after I
got home and I'm really thinking well
this is this is it it's been a day and a
half of this this is this is any second
now I get a call from my
agents um very very big fancy agents in
La that um you know I left a huge agent
agency to go with them took a chance it
worked for years I doubled my money and
tripled my money with touring with these
big fancier
agents and I get the call and they go
Tony uh really bad news it's coming from
above but um we have to let you go um we
can't associate
ourselves this is not our choice it's
coming from above you know these [__]
always blaming someone else which is
just ridiculous all the promises of a
bright future and building a crowd and
all of this
stuff um so guess what that sucks but
you know what sucks even
more is that's another news cycle they
put out a [__] press release saying
we disassociate ourselves with Tony
henchcliffe and racism of any kind so
boom CNN boom boom boom boom boom now
it's a day and a half and now that's the
biggest story drop by agency WME drops
Tony henchcliffe it's the biggest story
since the whole thing even
went um so there we are now and my
manager stuck with me the whole time and
again to know what it's like as a
comedian when it's a joke when it's not
right what's happening to you you know I
see people it's funny because getting
cancelled gets clumped in with people
that should be cancelled your Bill
Cosby's your Harvey Weinstein your this
is and that's rapists and sexual
assaulters disgusting humans and it kind
of gets clumped together getting
cancelled but there's a whole slew of
your Joe Rogan's your Tony hinch Cliffs
your Shane gillis's your Ari shaffir of
people that what you said something on a
podcast which is interesting because
this is even different than that and
again I'm scrambling in my brain the
whole time like wait even these guys got
in trouble for something they set on a
podcast how am I getting in trouble for
something that I said on a stage at a
comedy show to another comedian it why
it's still to this day makes no sense to
me but I get it the
disgusting Big media once their clicks
and you know they were bloodthirsty at
the time to see a especially I think a
Texan which made the story more
interesting to them or was just a year
or so earlier yeah a year earlier I was
a Californian I don't think it would
have rang the same their headline you
know comedian in La gets in trouble for
making fun of Asian comedian I think
Texan sounded better
um so there we are oh yeah so what I was
going to say is when you get cancelled
for a joke and it's not right what's
happening is you're getting I'm getting
phone calls continuously from the best
comedians in the world all my best Pals
and some people who at the time weren't
even my best Pals they were reaching out
just to give advice or ask how I'm doing
this is so wrong everybody was on one
side and one side only there was a
couple that are like gez why did you
have to go like that why'd you have to
go so hard shut the [__] get the [__]
out of here but everybody had different
advice that's what's interesting that's
where things get really [__] up and I
mean I'm talking about G Geniuses I'm
talking about the 10 best standups in
the world except for Chappelle Louis
Chris Rock Jerry Seinfeld very short
list of people that didn't call me but
everybody else had different advice one
guy says you should write a letter and
put it on Twitter one person says you
should type it and put it on Twitter one
person says you should make a video and
put it on Instagram one person says you
should explain what happened and put it
on Instagram one person says you should
apologize and put it on Instagram and
Twitter another person says you should
write an apology another genius says
that you should uh make a video of an
apology another one says you should make
a sketch about it and put that out
another one says go on stage do a set
about it and put that out literally
nobody there was very very few Shane
Gillis and Ari shaffir were the only two
that matched up which was whatever you
do do not apologize the third guy that I
golfed with me Ron White and the third
guy who's not a comedian and not in the
industry whatsoever also said whatever
you do do not apologize he said that
that day and he called me that night and
I I didn't know I don't even know how he
got my number and he called me that
night and he goes Tony I know you're
really going through it I saw your golf
game
earlier whatever you do don't
apologize meanwhile and I'm not going to
name any names but a lot of people say
look you just have to you have to say
some kind of apology just a quick little
hey I misspoke I did but I'm thinking to
myself I didn't misspeak it's jokes and
it's my style it's what I do if I want
to call somebody a [__] [__] or a
dick or this or that there's no magical
words to me if I think it's funny at
that time for that moment in that place
then that's me I'm the most professional
person to know I'm the doctor to
diagnose that special case right mhm
so I just and again I got to tell you so
many Geniuses of wild wild success and
wild wealth mentioned apologizing and I
just couldn't believe it but there's
still this tug of war even though I
don't want to and even though I'm
talking with them about I don't think
that's the right move I don't think it's
the right move it's so hard to tell
people that are you know wildly
successful um that I think they're wrong
about this especially when and the
entire world is going this is the worst
guy in the world right now and I'm
thinking to myself am I [__] crazy am
I losing my [__] mind am I really
wrong about this should I apologize for
making fun of somebody but I hold strong
now it's day three I ate I remember
eating a a slice of pizza that night the
second day and that was all that I ate
the entire day and as you can tell I'm
very skinny so if my metabolism is so
fast that if I miss a meal or two I look
skinny and gaunt and gross and now we're
basically waking up on
morning 72 hours right
24 24 48 well I guess it's 48 morning
3 I don't know anyway now I've
had a little bit of that Sushi before
the phone call with Joe and a slice of
pizza the next day maybe a slice and a
half I remember thinking I can't believe
how not hungry I am this is so weird
that I'm not hungry at all and I'm a
[__] I'm one of those like uh Joey
chestnuts type of characters you know
the hot dog eating champion you might
not be famous where you you you leave
your eggs on the
[__] but Joey chestnuts is a famous
skinny guy who beats everybody in the
world at eating hot dogs for some reason
he can eat [__] 300 hot dogs in 10
minutes and I eat like that I'm gross
like I can eat [__] a bowl of
spaghetti that big if I wanted to I
[__] hate you carry on it's amazing
and um so I remember thinking how am I
not
eating anyway but I'm just trying to
take you guys to what it's like you know
when you're
wronged by everybody and everything and
you know your friends are there for you
which is great but still when you open
your phone and you're on the front page
of [__] everything for a joke
mindboggling um and at this point let me
remind you that at this point you know
morning
three
um or the start of the third full day
let's put it that way right because it
started at [__] 5:30 a.m. on
technically Monday night Tuesday morning
so now we're waking up Thursday these
WME drops Tony hinchcliff articles are
everywhere and Pang dang is going on a
media
blitz accepting everything every single
thing that reached out to me he did yes
I can't believe what he did to me so
terrible and he's hasn't reached out in
any way he hasn't apologized he doesn't
care it seems like he's and he's adding
more stuff he's basically giving himself
away in a lot of ways in one um
interview he talks about how he saw me
the night before opening for Jo Rogan
and so he knew that I had Asian jokes
like he's like giving himself away now
it's starting to make sense to me so I
go okay he asked red ban if he can
record after he found out that he was
bringing me up like I start doing the
math on it and I don't know what happens
look I don't know how it works and I'm
sure deep down Pang dang is probably you
know somewhere in there a good guy that
just made a massive mistake and I don't
know how it works with China I I think
none of us do right it's a big
mysterious
blur the pandemic taught us that Tony
and I'd imagine you get rewarded though
for doing what they want I'd imagine
that
maybe I don't know whatever it may be
your side what I find kind of weird is
him doing that right he's still on 3,000
Twitter followers I'm like what did you
do this for oh it's crazy oh it's crazy
and you should see you know and I and
again you know I've never done anything
thing I could have I could have had the
entire I could have made it a thing I
could have made it my identity I could
have told the Kil Tony fan base let's
get him I could have done all of these
things and I just think he [__] up and
I think he knows he [__] up and I
think it's going to follow him
forever um in a way I kind of feel bad
for him but I don't CU it was a true
assassination attempt let there be no
question question this was not hurt
feelings this was not
um this was not it's not what he said it
was I don't believe it for a [__]
second he he contravened the Golden Rule
which is you do not do that to a
colleague oh yeah you do not see a joke
especially in a new material night and
then record it and put it on the
internet and then put create orchestrate
a pile on you don't do that and again
again the editing of the thing is
magical um you know about 15 20 seconds
after he uh cuts it at the end you know
um at the end of me I think the last
thing I say all you guys out here are
hooting and hollering like it seems like
I'm mad at the audience for laughing at
him the way that the clip goes but
what's funny is that if you watch the
video uh about 15 seconds after that um
I literally say come on lady relax
you're the only one not having fun what
do you think I'm being serious up here
like I'm literally I totally acknowledge
that I'm [__] just being a crazy dark
freak we'll be back with the interview
in one minute first we want to talk to
you about the sponsors of today's
episode ag1 we take ag1 to stay healthy
and Stave off illness whenever our
schedule gets really busy we used it on
our last America Tour where we were con
ly on the Move living out of a bag and
working every day one scoop a day meant
we knew we had all the vitamins and
minerals needed for the day we invested
in our health and had a hugely
successful trip as you saw ag1 is a
simple and easy way to get all the
nutrients you need each serving contains
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients if you're
looking for a simple and cost effective
supplement routine we recommend you try
ag1 and they're giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase to claim them just go to drink
a1.com
trigonometry go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink
a1.com
trigonometry to claim this special
offer so we're planning I'm thinking in
my head I can't I I can't 16 years of
doing this [__] [__] but I took the
hardest path you know I slept in my car
all the stupid old school comedian [__]
that you've heard about everybody you
know sleeping in my car behind The
Comedy Store working the door at the
store you know picking up shifts at the
coffee shop around the corner working
from 7:00 a.m. to 12 jumping on the
phones at The Comedy Store from 12:00 to
7:00 working the door of the comedy
store from 8:00 to 2:00 a.m. and then
waking up after sleeping in my car at
5:00 a.m. and working at the coffee shop
the next day I mean literally and I'm
thinking to myself is this happening to
me is this really it what can I do and
again you know of all the people again
Shane Gillis and Ari shaffir um you know
who had both gone through it Shane made
a joke on a podcast got canceled off of
SNL Ari shafir made a joke on Twitter uh
about Kobe BR and I think it was 2021
when Kobe died was it 2020 right 2020
yeah early 2020 I
think
and
um and uh they hold strong with the no
apology I'm talking with Ari a lot who
really really really really really ended
up When the Smoke cleared being my top
advisor which is kind of crazy because
he's a renegade you know a lawless
amazing big brother and I talked with
him about how you know I have the video
of his set and my set if he put out my
material why shouldn't I put out his
material in full length you know
retaliation is a hell of a thing as
we're probably going to find out with
this new Israel Palestine thing that's
happening you know you don't want to
mess with somebody that has the [__]
Iron Dome right I don't know if that
analogy makes any sense but iron D is
defensive so
no but still they've got resources I
think is what you're saying Tony yeah
but what I didn't want to do is I didn't
want to
um you know I wanted to get it out there
but I wanted to get it out through a
good vessel and it was actually Ari's
suggestion that we put out both sets his
set his whatever 10 minute set and my
whatever 15 minute set and let's just
put it out and let's not edit a thing
let's not speed up the intro like he did
let's leave his
anti-white pro- Asian and by the way
another thing that happened is that when
the clip that he put out happens and I
call him a filthy little seaword and I
go oh we make of the gunpowder we do a
this we do with that I do I hit like
three Asian stereotypes oh the soy sauce
I'm referencing what he was talking
about during his set literally that's
what he was talking about it sounds like
I'm rambling off these Chinese
stereotypes but it's him being a
cornball and me letting the audience
know you just saw a Chinese guy guy
doing corny Chinese jokes but again the
clip makes me look [__]
terrible um so we decide that we're
going to put it out on Ari shaffir's
YouTube channel and it was a wild
success I mean it blew up both sets back
to back showing that holy [__] Not only
was he doing unbelievable kind of I mean
really weirdly anti-white
material um and corny Asian jokes but I
you know just graze over it when you
watch both sets full length it's the 20
seconds that made world news for three
days is [__] nothing because it all
makes sense context is godamn everything
and the set that I had was fun and silly
again it was a workout set so I'm doing
crowd work I'm in and out I'm having fun
I'm very loose where he was doing a very
you know tight like he's like trying to
make it in Austin Texas that set that
set was a big deal to him and a shoot
around for
me so um the thing comes out and
he clamps up um he absolutely stops
every single scheduled media thing
because he realized he [__] up he had
no idea that I had the nuclear warhead
which is both of our sets
unedited um and I mean I got word from
someone that um he had to beg CBS to
stop uh from running a 60 minutes or
whatever it was like it was about to be
a big thing and it's him going please
stop I I can't I we can't I have to stop
like he hit full
breaks um and thank God you know what I
mean if I don't have that video and it's
funny because I just mentioned this
dinner with Joe we were talking about
how crazy cancellations are and I I go
if I didn't have that video of both sets
who the [__] knows where we're at and
instead people got to see that I was
just being me on a random night not
attacking somebody attacking somebody's
race and you know by the way if he would
have come up to me that night and said
anything we could have talked about it a
but that wasn't the thing that wasn't
what he wanted it's not what he needed
and it's not what would have benefited
him again whatever however this Chinese
media thing works whatever was supposed
to happen there I mean technically he's
a spy let's face it right technically in
some way what he was doing
was you know he's infiltrated America in
order to you know cause a Ruckus of some
kind there
there's how does the Chinese media
release that he tweets at 11:15 in
America when he didn't when it's not
11:15 in America and the [__] tweet
happens at 11:15 crazy right oh there's
a [__]
[Laughter]
drone
um Chinese fly drone yeah so um the
video gets released I go on stage on
Sunday night again Vulcan gas company a
random throwaway show that I'm not
scheduled to be on um I pop in and um to
the most amazing pop of Applause that
I've ever gotten in my entire life and
um
I talked about it and it was uh again
this is corny but I I was [__] like
almost emotional afterwards it was I was
it had been 5 days and there I was doing
what I loved to do and I had jokes about
it and it it's it's always been my
therapy you know again for a decade and
a half that's how I've handled
everything whether it be a friend that
kills themselves or a tragic accident or
a grandma dying or this or that or
whatever I do it on stage and there I
was talking about being on stage while
on stage five days after I'm thinking
maybe maybe I remember one comedy club
owner uh said you know and this is like
on the Wednesday this is like 24 hours
in she goes you know Tony in about a
year everything should be back to about
normal and there I was on
Sunday and everything was better than
normal and it changed me when you get
wronged um you're I think you're going
it it made me go after the laugh instead
of waiting for it to come to me I was
more bloodthirsty for um having a
[__] great set it's I'm going to show
you [__] that this isn't like
you know this is this is what I
do this is my
everything so anyway yeah that that such
a powerful lesson in that Tony cuz
there's a lot lot of people who would
have let that experience destroy them
who would have gone under and you can
understand it as well because it was
unfair it was a media pylon but I don't
think people watching this realize what
it means to an actor or an agent to or
to an actor or comedian to sign with a
big a agent I was going to say big agent
there that's a very different thing but
it's a moment of validation it's it's
that moment you've been working towards
the promised land you're going to be
able to get this or access and for all
of that to disappear like that because
of a joke you made at a new material
night when the entire rule of the new
material night is we're going to say
stuff it might not be funny and we might
cross the line but that's the point cuz
we're working it out
together on a Thursday night in my
hometown not listed on the show uh all
of it was a perfect storm of this isn't
right I'm an insult comedian and even
then here's another fun fact is my
Wikipedia changed that week that day or
whatever it went from American insult
comedian to you know disgraced comedian
or something like that immediately the
first line whatever it was disgraced is
that the right thing whatever it was but
it changed someone changed it from
insult comedian because it didn't match
their [__] storyline but it had been
insult comedian forever I didn't care I
don't even love the term insult comedian
I don't know who puts it there I don't
know who writes these things but they're
not that wrong I mean on stage my
standup isn't really ju it's not one you
know it's not uh one-sided like that
it's a little bit of a diverse portfolio
of making fun of a ton of stuff but um I
always found it interesting that that
was the first line and then it wasn't
the first line when I insulted somebody
when it was actually relevant right so
let me ask you something about the media
because I'm curious to know what you
think about whether they they were click
hunting whether they maybe just don't
know comedy maybe they didn't know
enough about you or do you think it was
malicious they they went after you
because they knew this was their moment
to make some I think it was multipronged
in that way I think you know a lot of
these articles had me as frequent Joe
Rogan guest friend of Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan
friend and at the time he's burying them
with a shovel and I mean he still is and
he was years before that and he's going
to be years he's talking to people about
vaccines at this time they're all piling
on 100% even the US government app
piling on Biden spoke about it well his
press secretary his press secretary yeah
spoke about what it spoke about Joe when
was that uh around that time oh yeah
yeah I mean yeah chaotic times totally
you think they were kind of going this
is a guy we can use to [__] on Joe that
I think it was perfect clickbait I I
think they had a weird thing with Asian
hate at the time I think I think um
they're coming off of the George Floyd
thing yeah and they're like ooh this
could be a new this could be a new
market for
us I'm serious I'm I'm not even kidding
I really they're [__] disgusting
they're nothing burgers and and you know
the a couple of them actually stuck me
on the phone they're so Sly and slimy I
no I'm not I don't know how they got my
number by the way which is also creepy
as they're [__] good getting your
number weird yeah and I go no thank you
I can't do it but I don't hang up the
phone I'm not interested in having any
statement on this whatsoever well are
you thinking about putting out a
statement I'm not really I you know they
they keep you on the phone the [__]
dirty dogs and that's their entire
everything
um you know so yeah I think it was a
mult multipronged effect that it was
racism less than a year after George
Floyd but in a whole new market kind of
like a new twist um the uh you
know
um I think there was you know I think
they loved downplaying standup comedy I
think that it hurts them to have people
really out there you know
single-handedly having a voice and an
opinion on things which is what they
really want right these media Outlets
want to sneak their opinion or their
take in on things and they supposedly
aren't allowed to but that obviously
changed half a decade ago or however
long ago when it started really being
silly
um but you know it the crazy thing is is
that when they try to cancel you and
they're wrong it makes you stronger I've
seen it with Ari shaffir I've seen it
with Shane Gillis I've seen it with
myself and we've all seen it with Joe
Rogan yeah when it's not real it makes
you stronger when it is real it I'm sure
it gets you I'm sure it takes you down I
don't see Cosby having a
Resurgence or any of those people you
know so many so many times I see
Weinstein on the front or back of my
favorite movies that I watch and he's
not coming back no when you did wrong
you're done if you didn't
you're bigger you can get bigger than
ever and it did again and it's not just
it made me famous it changed me again I
was going after the laughs I was
swinging the bat with [__] anger
instead
of I hope you think this is funny it's
[__] funny I was there was an animal
that kind of is created it's an I'm
going to show you mentality and you know
we started it was uh two weeks later we
started Kil Tony at Vulcan gas company
in front of 350 people instead of 100
people the viewership was bigger
stronger than ever and we've doubled
that continuously every few months since
then boom boom boom boom boom just keeps
getting bigger stand up the same thing
absolutely nonstop and at a different
temperature and you
know everything's just better than ever
now my agent is the agent that my old
agents hated more than anyone the
absolute head of comedy at the biggest
comedy agency not the second biggest
which is where I was before they dropped
me during the cancellation the number
one biggest and he's their worst
nightmare he's the guy that they see in
their nightmares it's that guy um and
I've gotten two calls from them my old
friends at WME in the last only two
months saying you know if you ever if
anything ever goes wrong over there we
would love to get back in the Tony
hinchcliff business and I cannot tell
you I cannot explain to you how much
[__] Joy it brings me I mean I just
sit on the other end of that phone and I
just play it cool I don't go I bet you
[__] do but my God am I thinking it
cuz when they get you like that when
you're down you know you don't forget
that all you don't forget that because
that is the sign of someone's character
oh yeah you sign when things go bad and
people start running or they walk away
or they take part in the Pyon or or you
go thank you thank you for showing me
you always remember the people who are
there for you and you never forget the
people who run it's just it's a very
simple thing about just as cowardly and
weak as I thought they were for dropping
me when the times were
dark I I I think that maybe even more
cowardly I find them crawling back with
sold out Arenas and sold out theaters on
my
schedule it's almost as disgusting to
beg for forgiveness when someone is
obviously thriving than it is to stab
them in the back when you know they are
down and out I mean how weak how gross
to show your character like that it's
unbelievable but
I like to [__] with them so I go yeah
yeah I'll keep I'll keep thinking about
that yeah if anything ever goes wrong if
if anything goes wrong with this uh and
again I mean it's literally like it's
the dream situation cuz it's the hope
that kills you oh yeah yeah they're
talking they're like no no no I swear
like he sounds fine yeah he six months
to a year he'll be back oh yeah yeah we
we built a strong
ra [__]
idiots morons it's good to have you on
the show it's good to see you thriving
yeah um and this is what this is you
know I started the interview by saying
when we had Uncle Roger on he said you
know this will show you're going when
you get canceled this is why we have
people on who've been canceled because
people need to hear this story they need
to hear that if you have been treated
unfairly don't apologize get the support
of your friends and you and then lean
into it and we saw you do a stand a set
at the mothership and I can totally feel
what you're talking about you're like an
animal on stage now you really are you
go on there there's no apology there's
no hesitation you you go on there with
Supreme confidence I love to see it so
congratulations on your success man it's
awesome to see and people who get
canceled need to see this too right yeah
this is this is how you beat cancel
culture is people who get cancelled come
back stronger that's how you win don't
apologize if you didn't do something
wrong if you did do something wrong
apologize yeah absolutely here's here
here's here's something that I didn't
mention that I thought about a lot
during that actually Tony save it for
locals because we've got to ask some
questions from our audience head on over
to locals guys we'll talk about what
Tony wants to talk about and ask your
questions as well we'll see you on
there we promised our audience you would
roast us you look like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
if